le jour se lève à peine sur kiev
lorsque l'alerté donnée les frappes ont
ciblé ce site en banlieue sud de la
capitale
une usine d'armement totalement détruite
moscow revendique cette attaque ce soir
des missions calibre à longue portée et
de haute précision lancé depuis la mer
ont frappé une installation militaire à
la périphérie de kiev le nombre et
l'ampleur des frappes de missiles sur
des cibles à kiev augmenteront en
réponse à toute attaque terroriste
ou sabotage du régime nationaliste de
kiev sur le territoire russe
allusion aux bombardements de deux
villages russe à la frontière avec
l'ukraine kiev rejette toute
responsabilité
en revanche ce que le président hélène
ce qui assume et revendique celle
attaques de ce croiseur russe le masque
va touché par un missile le navire
amiral a sombré en mer noire
l'emmental nationale vient soutenir les
ukrainiens qui ont démontré que les
navires us jeux peuvent que couler
moscou nie toute agression mais
reconnaît des dégâts liés à l'explosion
de munitions quelles que soient les
circonstances dans lesquelles le masque
va a coulé sa perte est un nouveau
revers pour la russie en mars dernier la
marine ukrainienne prenait pour cible un
autre bâtiment clé le navire de
transport de troupes lorsque tout près
du port occupé de berlioz qu à 80 km de
marioupol